ahora veamos la eliminación contra
sustitución para un sustrato secundario
estos son un poco más difíciles que para
un sustrato primario o terciario porque
los cuatro mecanismos de reacción son
posibles
entonces si analizamos la estructura de
nuestro sustrato ya dijimos que es
secundario pero ahora analicemos el
reactivo
aquí tenemos n hace el que sabemos que
está compuesto por n a más cl - y el año
en cloruro solamente funciona como un
núcleo filo así que esperaríamos una
sustitución núcleo física por lo tanto 1
y 2 quedan fuera y estamos en 3 n 1 y sn
2 porque tenemos un sustrato secundario
pero no estamos seguros de cuál de los
dos hasta que analicemos el solvente y
miren en este caso el dms o es un
solvente polar a pro tico que como vimos
en vídeos anteriores favorece el
mecanismo sn 2 entonces s
uno queda fuera ok vamos a pensar en el
año en cloruro que funciona como un
núcleo filo lo dibujaré por aquí tiene
una carga formal negativa en un
mecanismo sn dos el núcleo filo ataca al
mismo tiempo que se va el grupo saliente
y nuestro núcleo filo ataca a este
carbono de color rojo entonces formamos
un enlace entre el cloro y el carbono de
color rojo y cuando el núcleo filo ataca
también se va el grupo saliente estos
electrones se van con el oxígeno y
sabemos que el tos y la tos es un buen
grupo saliente así que cuando dibujamos
nuestro producto
ahí está el carbono rojo corresponde a
este carbono y sabemos que en un
mecanismo sn dos ocurre la inversión de
la configuración el núcleo filo tiene
que atacar por el lado opuesto al grupo
saliente entonces si aquí tenemos al
grupo saliente en una cuña eso significa
que en el producto tenemos al cloro
representado con una línea punteada ese
es el producto de nuestra reacción sn 2
para el siguiente problema aquí tenemos
un alero de alquilo secundario entonces
al ver todas las reacciones no podemos
hacer mucho porque las cuatro son
posibles pero analicemos el reactivo en
un vídeo anterior vimos que el de vn es
una base fuerte y no funciona como un
núcleo filo
así que sn 1 y sn 2 quedan fuera pero
una base fuerte significa que es una
reacción de dos así que uno también
queda afuera entonces ahora que sabemos
que estamos haciendo un mecanismo de
reacción y dos analicemos la estructura
de nuestro haluro de alquilo miren el
carbono que está unido directamente al
halógeno es el carbono alfa y los
carbonos unidos directamente al carbono
alfa son los carbonos beta entonces
pondré el carbono de la derecha como
beta porque finalmente son iguales
y sabemos que la base toma un protón de
ese carbono beta aquí tenemos un
hidrógeno y el de vn es una base neutra
entonces pongamos una base general
nuestra base toma este protón al mismo
tiempo que estos electrones se mueven
para formar un doble enlace y estos
electrones se van junto con el bromo
para formar el año en bromuro entonces
nuestro producto final es un al que no y
estos electrones de color rosa se
movieron para formar el doble enlace en
el siguiente problema tenemos otro
alumno de alquilo secundario nuevamente
tenemos estas cuatro posibilidades hasta
que analicemos el reactivo y en este
caso es hidróxido de sodio n a más o
menos y sabemos que el ión hidróxido
puede funcionar como un núcleo filo
fuerte o también como una base fuerte
por lo tanto un núcleo filo fuerte nos
hace pensar en una reacción sn 2 y no
una s n 1 y la base fuerte nos hace
pensar en una reacción de dos y no en la
1 y como tenemos calor el calor favorece
a una reacción de eliminación sobre una
reacción de sustitución así que es la
reacción de dos y si analizamos nuestro
alumno de alquiló el carbono unido al
halógeno es nuestro carbono alfa y el
carbono unido directamente a ese es
nuestro carbono beta aquí tenemos dos
carbonos beth vamos a enumerar el anillo
digamos que el carbono alfa es el
carbono 1 y si vamos en dirección a las
manecillas del reloj tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 y
ok y ahora pasemos esto a la
conformación de sí ya que tenemos aquí
entonces el carbono 1 sería este carbono
y el carbono todos sería este así que
este es el carbono 3 4 5 y 6
ahora el bromo se encuentra hacia
nosotros en el carbono 1 eso significa
que va hacia arriba entonces en el
carbono 1 tenemos al bromo hacia arriba
se encuentra en posición axial hacia
arriba y en el carbono 2 tenemos un
grupo metilo que se encuentra lejos de
nosotros así que va hacia abajo en la
conformación de silla entonces en el
carbono 2 tenemos un grupo metilo que se
encuentra en posición axial pero hacia
abajo entonces si nos interesa el
carbono 2 que es el carbono beta y
también nos interesa el carbono 6 que
también es un carbono beta entonces
pongamos los hidrógenos en esos carbonos
beth vamos a ver en el carbono 2 tenemos
un hidrógeno hacia arriba en posición
ecuatorial y en el carbono 6 tenemos un
hidrógeno axial hacia abajo y 1
ecuatorial hacia
entonces si pensamos en el mecanismo 2
sabemos que la base fuerte toma un
protón y ese protón debe de estar en
posición anti peri planar al halógeno
entonces como el halógeno que en este
caso es el bronx se encuentra en
posición axial necesitamos tomar un
protón que se encuentre en posición anti
peri planar a ese bromo y miren si
analizamos primero el carbono 2 aquí no
tenemos un hidrógeno anti peri planner
al halógeno pero si tenemos uno en el
carbono 6 que es este hidrógeno en
posición axial hacia abajo entonces
nuestra base toma ese protón dibujemos
el ión hidróxido que es una base fuerte
el hidróxido toma este protón con lo que
estos electrones se mueven para formar
un doble enlace al mismo tiempo que
estos electrones se van junto con el
bromo para formar el ión bromuro
dibujemos el producto
aquí tenemos el anillo y cómo se forma
un doble enlace entre el carbono 1 y el
carbono 6 eso significa que el doble
enlace se forma aquí y después en el
carbono 2 aún tenemos un grupo metilo
lejos de nosotros ahí está entonces los
electrones de color rojo se mueven aquí
para formar el doble enlace entre el
carbono 1 y el carbono 6
este es el carbono 1 y este es el
carbono 6 así podemos comparar el
producto con el compuesto inicial y
miren este es el producto mayor que se
obtiene en nuestra reacción y 2 pero
también es posible obtener un poco de
otros productos con una reacción sn 2
pero cómo se aplica calor una reacción
de eliminación es más favorecida que una
de sustitución
aquí tenemos un alcohol secundario con
ácido fosfórico y calor y hemos visto
mucho este tipo de problemas en los
vídeos sobre reacciones de eliminación
así que sabemos que no será sn uno ni sn
dos y como no tenemos una base fuerte
tampoco es de dos sino más bien
uno y nuestro primer paso es la proto
nación del alcohol para formar un mejor
grupo saliente entonces en este caso el
ácido fosfórico es la fuente de protones
así que en el primer paso vamos a protón
ar este oxígeno dibujemos el anillo y
como protón amos el oxígeno
ahora el oxígeno está unido a dos
hidrógenos y aún tiene un par de
electrones libres y todo eso le da una
carga formal positiva al oxígeno
entonces este par de electrones libres
en el oxígeno tomaron un protón del
ácido fosfórico y formaron este enlace
ahora ya tenemos un mejor grupo saliente
que el guión hidróxido entonces estos
electrones se van junto con el oxígeno y
como le quitamos un enlace a este
carbono de color rojo obtenemos un carbó
catión secundario dibujemos nuestro
carbó catión secundario y el carbono
rojo es este carbono que ahora tiene una
carga formal positiva ok ahora tenemos
agua que puede funcionar como una base
débil en nuestra reacción de 1 así que
puede tomar un protón de uno de los
carbonos que se encuentre junto al
carbono con la carga positiva por
ejemplo este carbono está unido a dos
hidrógenos pero solo dibujemos uno
entonces el agua funciona como una base
toma este protón y estos electrones se
mueven hacia acá para formar un doble
enlace dibujemos el producto final aquí
tenemos el anillo y por acá tenemos el
doble enlace
estos dos carbonos entonces estos
electrones de color rosa se movieron
para formar el doble enlace nuestro
producto es el ciclo hexano entonces un
alcohol secundario puede reaccionar
mediante el mecanismo 1 si tenemos algo
como ácido sulfúrico o ácido fosfórico y
lo calentamos para esta reacción
tenemos este alumno de alquilo
secundario que reacciona en una solución
acuosa de ácido fórmico ahora el ácido
fórmico es un núcleo filo débil y el
agua es un solvente polar pro tico
entonces un núcleo filo débil y un
solvente polar pro tico nos hacen pensar
en un mecanismo de reacción sn 1 porque
el agua al ser un solvente polar pro
tico puede estabilizar la formación de
un kart vocación entonces si estos
electrones se van junto con el bromo y
le quitamos un enlace a este carbono de
color rojo el carbono rojo tendrá
una carga formal positiva dibujemos el
carb ocasión aquí tenemos nuestro anillo
de benceno y vamos a poner los
electrones pi y el carbono de color rojo
es este carbono entonces ese carbono
ahora tiene una carga formal positiva y
miren este es un kart vocación
secundario pero también es un kart
vocación bencílico entonces la carga
positiva en realidad está deslocalizada
debido a los electrones bien el anillo
así que esto es más estable que la
mayoría de los carbó cationes
secundarios y bueno si pensamos en un
mecanismo de reacción sn uno el carb
ocasión sería el electro filo y el
núcleo filo sería el ácido fórmico y en
un vídeo anterior vimos que el oxígeno
del carbón y lo es más núcleo físico que
este oxígeno entonces un par de
electrones libres en este oxígeno ataca
al carbono de color rojo y así obtenemos
dibujemos el resulta
del ataque núcleo físico no veremos
todos los pasos del mecanismo porque ya
lo habíamos visto en otro vídeo en el de
los mecanismos de reacción s n 1 y s n 2
entonces en nuestro producto final aquí
tenemos un carbono unido con un doble
enlace a un oxígeno y aquí tenemos un
hidrógeno
este es nuestro producto y este carbono
es un centro quiral y como éste es un
mecanismo de reacción s n 1 y tenemos
una geometría plana en nuestro carbó
catión el núcleo fi lo puede atacar por
los dos lados así que terminaremos con
una mezcla de enantiómero y bueno si
quieren conocer más detalles de este
mecanismo porque la verdad me he saltado
algunos pasos por favor vean el vídeo
sobre ese n 1 y sn 2 resumen final y
bueno pensemos en qué más podría pasar
vamos a ver es n 2 queda fuera porque se
forma un kart vocación no es posible
porque tenemos un kart buque
y también hay una base débil presente
porque la base débil podría ser el agua
entonces dibujaré una base general por
aquí y vamos a dibujar uno de los
protones que tenemos en este carbono
nuestra base puede tomar este protón con
lo que estos electrones se mueven hacia
acá para formar un doble enlace así que
otro posible producto es vamos a ver
aquí tenemos el anillo de benceno y
después tenemos un doble enlace entonces
otra posibilidad es un mecanismo e1